they're all live oysters this is all
live oysters
so they're everywhere i'm here in maine
on north haven island
where i'm going to harvest oysters with
adam a local farmer
of america's favorite mollusk
this little tiny bed can produce 250 to
300 000 oysters a year
i'm walking through the water thinking
so where are these things i'm actually
standing on them it was a proper oyster
bed
they're free nothing's caged nothing's
in racks
the size of this they're all the
tomatoes that is insane
what an amazing little river so the
fresh water comes from
uh freshwater pond up here yep and then
the tide comes from the sea yes and then
the two meet and it creates
really good algae blooms yeah so they
get the advantage of the tides obviously
and the flow and the flow and so that's
a gorgeous one that's a beauty there
yeah
the extreme tidal fluctuations of this
history and the mixing of fresh and salt
water
are a part of what makes this the
perfect environment
to grow the oysters how did they get
here
um i grew oysters in the pond for years
and i had this kid harvesting for me
and he shucked the oyster and dropped
them on the bed and they created a
natural spawn so i
came down the next morning and the whole
17 acre pond
had three feet of foam on it and i was
like oh my god what's going on
wow some of the oyster larvae swam into
this connected estuary where they ended
up thriving
on the gravel bottom so adam now
replicates this process
for each new batch actually you want to
oyster once i want to operate i don't
know i'd love one now it's please yeah
you're kidding me
look at that oh my god
share that thank you just look at the
color
my god they're nice and thick dense
creamy
cheese look at that cheers
bloody hell man there's a reason i have
five kids
guess how many kids i've got how many
that's awesome for me it makes a big
difference having these free-range
bottom cultured oysters because
they're spread out there's nothing set
in cages they're not hanging
horizontally
vertically they literally are laying on
the bed
of that river and then this surge of
salt water
against the fresh water it's just
producing you know a perfect oyster
honestly some of the best oysters i've
ever eaten oh my god
all right let's go smoke some big ones
[Music]
so these oysters here are market oysters
so this is like half shell market
gotcha the big ones like this one we got
today that is not
a half shell oyster how did you open
something like that i'll shut this one
please check it out oh
man look at that i mean honestly
wow so then we'll brine that overnight
yeah and then that is beautiful
so beautiful and then this is what it
looks like after 24 hours of smoking oh
my god
right here so they've already been
browned they're brine
smoked wow yeah
um that's delicious yeah and then the
way we finish them
is in is another process yup
[Music]
we pack them in um virgin olive oil with
a couple other little secret ingredients
i love them with secrecy we gotta have a
few secrets that smells sweet is there
honey in there
yeah there is see you got me you got me
chefs share their secrets right yeah
yeah one's enough
my god wow that is so good
smoked oysters are out there you know
it's a fine balance when something's so
salty creamy and delicious
but amazing flavor what works for me
there is that honey
any herbs in there oh you're not gonna
tell me you're such a
i know melissa won't have a jar like
that may i take the fresh oysters
yep the clams and just ajar because that
could be the secret weapon
do it yeah take it thanks bud share the
love i think i've become a mainer
now i've got to cook like one so these
little pockets of magic
fingers crossed is gonna have the edge
over melissa all right cool take care
awesome
thank you all right
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips
you